biggest mistake they would do is to try
to uh save uh the the first or the
initial implementation
cost or uh implement it internally in
the company whenever they don't have a
revs function of course like the early
stages company that's that's the biggest
mistake because then when whenever they
get to to be a
midsize they would have this old mess
already uh and they will call us to say
please help us because we can't do with
this we can't we can't work uh it's just
like a sometimes like the CRM or the
systems are becoming sort of like data
boxes they're not really they they don't
contain a real process or they contain
too many processes that affect that
conflicts each other
Rosie pinassi welcome to 20 minute
leaders I'm so happy to have you here
how are you great how are you thank you
for inviting me of course so good to
have you here Rosie you're the H CEO of
of scal Ops H experience really looking
at how to scale operations right I mean
it's it's kind of in the name and uh
your background I think really speaks to
your experience with with looking at how
do these different systems and how to
look at op operations at scale and so
I'm really excited to dive into this
world with you understand a little bit
about you know the evolving world how do
organizations adapt to scalable
operations and how you're assisting them
in doing so so so Rosie tell me a little
bit about yourself your journey how you
even got here yeah actually it's a funny
story you know
um I studied accounting and I thought
I'm going to be a great
accountant um and and
um I was a research uh assistant in the
university and uh I started to look for
an
internship uh and then I realized that
I'm not able to find an internship
because uh they all said no
basically um and I thought okay I'll do
just like a
break I'll go to search a temporary job
just like to start with something and
then I'll come back and search search my
um my intership again and my journey and
so forth uh and uh I got accepted to
converse as a business operations and
that was like a temporary job and
Converse was back then like a big a nice
company and they had like a a lot of
business Ops
people um I was uh part of the
maintenance of the business op
operations like uh the the services they
provided uh and that's how my journey
started and I thought it's going to be
like um a temporary job of six months
that was uh that was the intention back
then uh and then it grew up and I was
there for four years so that's how it
started um as so as I said that fun yeah
yeah yeah I I I had so much fun there
yeah I was the young Because by the way
I was 22 so I had no clue about nothing
it took me like uh 6 months to
understand what is
booking um yeah it was just like at the
beginning of of the
journey um so I was there for four years
and it was like a really big company so
I like you like you couldn't see
everything in terms of like
understanding the o to cash but you do
have or you do learn about processes how
to uh Implement processes but also like
how to understand work with
crms uh work with data um install base
and so forth uh and then like after four
years I decided to start working in a
startup in a smaller place in order to
understand like the whole process from
lead to cach uh I started to research
about it to learn about it um and I got
into a startup 30 people in it was
perfect uh I
learned the old funnel I would say from
marketing to sales to service to
customer success uh got to understand
the um the systems the processes the
people the functions the the Departments
whatever everything it's a very like um
diverse diverse uh uh position I would
say um and then uh decided that I'm
going to have like more companies to
work with and this is basically how it
started because I became a
freelancer and I started with a lot of
Education because back then there
weren't so many startups who had this
role in their company I'm talking about
2017 uh people still didn't know so when
I started to
to try to provide my services or have a
certain Consulting people asked me are
you doing sales are you doing marketing
are you an SDR you're an SDR right no no
I'm not an SDR I'm not marketing I'm not
sales um I started to educate I started
to write articles about it case studies
and so forth and then I realized that
it's it's harder so uh I decided to work
through a system start with working
through a system and I wanted to be
become a Salesforce partner
uh they said no you're too
small um so I went and became a hopspot
partner uh succeeded to be a hopspot
partner and start to started to provide
my services on top of hopspot uh I came
mainly from the sales side from the
sales operations side so I was uh uh
partnering with a another marketing
agency uh that later on uh we uh
acquired their business and provided my
sales operation Services um it was
mainly connecting uh hopspot and
Salesforce in terms of like the both
like the funnel and um
systems um and that that's basically was
my freelance
period um
once people became more more aware about
the revenue operations sales operations
marketing operations
they started to um to to reach out and
uh it grew and I had like the idea of
maybe I should hire
someone uh so I hired first person I
told her at the beginning I'm not sure
how it's going to look like and she was
very open to it she's still with us
she's our coo today
Nelly um but then it grew it grew to the
second person and the third person and
the fifth person and um
I'm happy to say that most of our people
are still in the company running with us
in the last four
years um and yes that's like that's
basically basically the journey we've
been doing a lot of education and
content since then because we know that
it's it's still growing revops is still
growing and um and
yeah so what is revops so if you take me
back for second to more the foundations
of this work that you're doing you
mentioned what it's not but but what is
it so it's connecting
between processes
systems people and
strategy um that is revops so basically
it's starting from like if we are
starting from the foundation it's
starting from data from good data that
you have that you would need to have as
part of your marketing or sales or
customer success uh department but where
do you put this data is it on Excel is
it on like a certain system and then
it's connecting it's connecting us to
the system because we would need to uh
plan Define design the system in order
for you to enter the the the data in it
so systems people processes and strategy
and the strategy is the best part
because eventually
like you don't want a revops person to
be too much technical you don't want a
revops person to have uh like to to
control everything on technical side but
don't like not understand the business
not not understand the data see the data
and don't understand like that won't be
able to uh um understand it
reflects um So eventually what what we
do in terms of the strategy is also like
understanding the marketing needs the
sales
needs um their
goals and to know how to connect it with
with the systems uh and eventually show
uh the dashboards and the reports and
everything which needs to
be um connected as well with the
management
um with the management part in the
company so that's that's basically what
we do I think it's a connection of a
few really important components uh in
the company so walk me through how you
would engage with a company in the in
this context and what do you bring to
the table with your experience in both
the technical implementation but then
also the strategy aspect and and what
what are you finding are sort of the key
patterns that are repeating across these
different organizations you're working
with so I think one of the like whenever
we started I could say that we started
as a hopspot partner and uh there are
not many revops companies uh in Israel
and in the
world and um we're not we're not a hop
spot partner as an integrator or
Salesforce partner as an integrator
that's not where we meant to
be um the the idea of thinking broadly
about the company and and the processes
uh that's like a part of the
strategy so understanding how it starts
like what we would need to do in order
to get the leads what we would need to
do after we get the leads how we convert
them into an opportunity how we take
this opportunity into the process like
of sales
pipeline how we close this opportunity
and what how we close this opportunity
and what happens after do you need do do
you have a renewal process do you have a
customer success who needs to be
involved do you have a service uh
support person who would need to be
involved like try to understand the
process from lead to cash even finances
involved uh some of the time depend the
company but yes that's that's the
idea understanding all strategy behind
it and know how to structure it and uh
establish a mirror board or something in
order to see how it all goes and then
Define exactly what are the system or
were which are going to support that um
that's that's part of the the strategy
understanding the business model of the
company because based on that you also
build the structure or the the
infrastructure of the of the system so
you will have to understand how to
technically build it but you
like have to see it broadly first before
before you start uh and that's start
strategy part that's what we do that's
what we do with uh many companies we've
been working with many many many
companies today we work with uh actually
uh more uh midsize and Enterprises I
would say and yes know how what do you
see is and so I'm curious you know
you're you're working you've gotten a
chance to work with a lot of comp how
many companies would you say youve you
worked with until now and either you
yourself or with scale UPS yeah on these
types of things hundreds hundreds of
companies wow okay so you're a so you're
a walking chat GPT on Reva s and Company
strategy and implementations so what do
you see are the common maybe mistakes
that um that organizations do either at
the early stages or later stages of
thinking through these operations and
revops um that you know I and other
entrepreneurs can take with us as as
important you know feedback and and
things to keep in mind the biggest
biggest biggest mistake they would do is
to try to
uh save uh the the first or the initial
implementation
cost or uh implement it internally in
the company whenever they don't have a
revs function of course like the early
stages company that's that's the biggest
mistake because then when whenever they
get to to be a
midsize they would have this old mess
already uh and they will call us to say
please help us because we can't do it we
can't we can't work uh it's just like um
sometimes like the CRM or the systems
are becoming sort of like data boxes
they're not really they they don't
contain a real process or they contain
too many processes that affect that
conflicts each other um so it's really
really really important to have someone
on board or someone responsible for the
implementation whether it's like a
someone internal who knows it and did it
already a few times or uh someone who's
like who's experienced in it I think
that's like
a one of the biggest mistakes we've
we've seen with uh with companies um we
came through like we we we also like had
some consultations uh that we did and so
forth um and sometimes it seems to be
very easy right like the the lead comes
in and then the salesperson calls and
then like there is the pipeline and
everything looks like working but you
would
nearly like really understand and
understand how to build like this
infrastructure in order to scale it
later not just like how you have it like
for one per salesperson but if you're
looking to uh invest in your sales and
higher five or 10 sales person you would
need to have the understanding of how
the infrastructure would look like
because those five people or 10 people
they're not going to work the same
they're not going to have the same
process if they don't have a process or
they have to have maybe like a sales
Playbook or um a certain documentation
of how they work with with the CRM how
they update the data eventually What's
um what I always like to say is that
um a CRM and like all those systems are
like um a muslo
pyramid and why is that in muslo pyramid
you have uh the basic
needs so that's the data and the
infrastructure whenever you don't have
or you don't feel the basic needs you
cannot survive right so that's the same
whenever we don't have a clear data
whenever we don't have a good
infrastructure uh whenever the fields we
have dupli we have duplications
or extra
properties uh that we don't need it's
becoming too messy and we don't
basically we're not able to have the
first step of the
pyramid um so that's exactly the the
next step in the CRM is the processes to
have a clear process that the cells uh
people know how to work it
through and of course to monitor it and
to understand that it's working
improving it it's an ongoing process
it's not like a onetime click and that's
all and the last uh the the part
everyone wants to get is like have an
amazing dashboard or have a very nice
automation that could work in the CRM in
order for you to have your work more
efficient to have to spend more customer
facing time and so forth but you won't
be able to get this amazing dashboard or
automation if you don't have like the
right infrastructure for it so whenever
we get uh to a midsize company and they
don't have the right infrastructure we
have to start with the infrastructure in
order to get to the Automation and the
dashboard so that's something that is
very important to know and uh understand
and try to to establish it from the
beginning and not get to a messy
situation
after I I love it okay and if you had
one tip to give to organizations as we
are now you know entering the era of
intelligence and and the Integrations of
AI into all of these systems what what
is one thing to keep in mind or or one
tip that you would give us oh okay so
it's uh it depends
uh if that's an early stage or like a
midsize or an Enterprise because I think
it would be it would be different
um I would say the adoption part uh is
one of the most important uh Parts in
the company as the and the most
challenging part uh whenever
you uh try to get your salesperson not
to work with Exel but to start to work
with the CRM and have a certain process
uh and monitor that uh that's something
that would be very very very important
to have at like as an early let's say as
an early stage of a company because like
midsize and Enterprises they have so
many challenges that I could talk about
but it's like as as as an early stage
company uh the adoption part would be
very
important um
to monitor that uh to have uh the
CRM uh process fits to the to the
salesperson or to the uh sales team um
that that would make uh the data uh more
transparent eventually to the management
uh or to the people who are looking into
the data and wants to get like decisions
and it's very very critical as an early
stage company uh because th those
decisions are uh changing very very fast
and you would need to get the uh fast
decisions so uh to have like a full
transparency in the CRM would be very
important uh so it it starts from the
adoption uh and from the use of the CRM
so that would be my my
tip amazing Rosie I really want to thank
you for a a short but meaningful
conversation it went it always goes by
way too fast H but I uh I'm fully
convinced that you know this the the
world of of the strategy and operations
especially when it comes to revops and
the ability to implement these
strategies in a technical way that then
just boosts your ability to work with
maso's pyramid as you say with the data
and infrastructure layer but then to
build on top of that that's really where
where a lot of the value is and uh so I
want to wish you best of luck with scal
Ops and uh thank you again for taking
the time to be here with me thank you m
have a great day thank you so much